[Musik]
junge ich will keine werbung alter
zweimal werbung hintereinander kommt
hier ich drehe ab hey leute was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich kann gerade nicht auf den
tisch hauen wie sonst nur weil vor mir
steht schon eine kamera ich habe nämlich
was interessantes also ja ich habe seit
vorgestern ios 4 10
das update ich habe es eigentlich nicht
so mit updates weil ich hatte schon so
oft einfach die erfahrung und
hauptsächlich eigentlich auf dem imac
oder auf meinem macbook dass wenn ich
mir das neue update geholt habe
irgendwas ging dann einfach plötzlich
nicht mehr was ich brauchte eben
software keine ahnung final cut fotos
von bastia format deswegen warte ich
eigentlich immer ein bisschen ein
bisschen neues update wurde aber es 14
hab ich mir jetzt direkt gezogen und ich
habe mich mal ein bisschen schlau
gemacht es gibt nämlich echte menge sehr
coole features die damit gekommen sind
und ich habe mir gedacht die könnte ich
eigentlich mal vorstellen also wirklich
sehr coole sachen ich war auch
überrascht und ich würde sagen wir
starten einfach mal nett scope ich
glaube das bietet sich eigentlich ganz
gut an damit einzusteigen und zwar kann
man zum beispiel jetzt hier komplett
einmal rüber vision und dann hat man
hier so eine app mediathek mit allen
apps ihr habt das heißt wenn ihr keinen
bock mehr habt das irgendwie eine app
wie whatsapp absolut unwichtig wäre wenn
uns heutzutage wir nicht mehr erscheinen
soll haltet ihr die einfach gedrückt
geht dann auf entfernen und könnt ihr
dann in die app mediathek bewegen dh wir
haben die dann nur noch hier
vorzufindenden gut das wollte ich es
natürlich nicht und habe es wieder
rückgängig gemacht weshalb ist jetzt
wieder hier auf dem home-bildschirm also
eigentlich echt ganz cool würde ich mal
sagen machen weiter mit dem nächsten ich
habe mir die hier alle aufgeschrieben
also die dich am coolsten finde ich will
jetzt nicht jedes machen weil es gibt
noch eine menge mehr wenn ihr meint alex
macht alle dann lass gern mal daumen
nach oben da oder so dann suche ich alle
mal zusammen okay wir gehen einfach mal
hier auf die notizen erstellen eine neue
notiz und gehen hier auf das
schreibwerkzeug keine ahnung
einfach diesen diesen fehler genau
machen wir einen dicken und jetzt
richtig dicken hier heute oder einen
richtig dicken und jetzt könnt ihr
dieses vorschlag folge wo spongebob so
richtig gerade kreise mal das kann ich
jetzt nämlich auch wir malen einfach
einen ganz entspannten co oder war schon
so sehr rund und haben jetzt einfach
einen ganz kundenkreis mann oder das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch mit einem
viereck in dem kreistag picasso 2.0
sitzt jetzt hier für euch also das wird
auf jeden fall auf man kann einfach
gerade zeichnen einfach das symbol mal
was auch immer es geht eigentlich alles
machen man files sagte auch dass die und
dann bevor ihr los lasst einfach
gedrückt halten dann entsteht halten
gerade pfeilgerade kreis gerade ist es
recht grades dreieck was auch immer
dreieck zack zack
wir haben das ist jetzt nicht ganz so
gerade egal weiter geht es mit dem
nächsten was ich wirklich ultras finde
wir gehen hier auf die einstellungen
gehen dann auf bedienungshilfen und dann
einfach mal auf tippen und hier dann auf
ganz unten steht hier auf rückseite
tippen und da können wir jetzt für
doppel tippen einfach irgendeinen befehl
festlegen zum beispiel wir machen hier
ein screenshot also bildschirmfoto ok
und drei mal tippen machen wir
ton aus okay leute und jetzt haltet euch
fest ich tippe hinten zweimal drauf 12
und boom screenshot zu wild und jetzt
habe ich drei mal 123 und sturm modus 1
123 und sturm modus aus ja an sich ich
weiß nicht ob man das braucht aber ist
krass dass das iphone das hier hinten
einfach erkennt also ich weiß nicht
genau wie dort geht weil das war ja
nicht direkt beim iphone 11 dabei das
wurde ja sozusagen nachträglich
geupdatet schon heftig nennt die technik
heutzutage wird weiter geht es zur
nächsten absolut wilden erfindung wir
gehen hier auf die einstellungen und
gehen dann hier wieder in die
bedienungshilfen zack und können mal
runter scrollen hierzu geräusch
erkennung machen die geräusch erkennung
mal anfügen hier geräusche hinzu wie zum
beispiel autohupe türklingel katz wenn
man halt eine katze zu hause hat und
hund meinetwegen auch vielleicht habt
ihr mal kopfhörer drin und hört nicht
euer handy herz dann aber ich mache
jetzt einfach mal einem jahr eine katze
an
und dann sollte das iphone das
eigentlich zeigen junge ich will keine
werbung alter zweimal werbungen
hintereinander kommt ich dreh ab
so hier jetzt haben wir's für mich es
wurde ein geräusch erkannt dass wie eine
katze klingt ja es war auch eine katze
allerdings ein lustiges katzen und
kätzchen mia und compilation 2015
vielleicht lag's daran also der hat es
echt ich schnell erkannt ich mache
jemanden türklingel sound okay das ging
jetzt besser ja also habt ihr
wahrscheinlich verstandene schon krass
weg vielleicht auch erst mal ein
bisschen unnötig aber wenn man mal
genauer darüber nachdenkt so schlecht
ist das vielleicht gar nicht wenn ihr
eine katze oder ein hund zu hause ab
oder keine ahnung auf die tür nicht hört
was weiß nicht wo bei da sicherlich auch
viele sagen ich will nicht abgehört
werden gut jedem das seine ich brauche
es auch nicht deswegen mache ich auch
wieder aus genau was ich euch auch mal
eben zeigen wollte und zwar wir nehmen
hier ein foto ein schönes urlaubsfoto
von mir sonst war es immer nur möglichst
so bis hierhin zu suchen dann wurde das
automatisch wieder zurückgezogen das war
ein bisschen scheiße wenn man mal sehen
wollte was genau hier ganz hinten ab
geht ihr seht es sollte man kann einfach
bis ganz hinten rein suchen also das ist
halt ganz nice so muss sich ein
screenshot machen wo du gesagt hast um
dann noch ein screenshot zu machen wo du
wieder kommen für drei interessenten
locken screenshot zu machen wo du wieder
komplett gesund das war vorher nicht
komplett ganz komplett reinigen konnten
fans ihr das halt sparen und direkt
komplette schön rein zoomen und sehen
was da hinten auf mehr abgeht wir
bleiben jetzt hier einfach mal bei dem
bild und vision so hoch und dann
erscheint hier bild titel hinzufügen ich
schreibe jetzt mal der boss weil ich bin
halt auf dem foto zu sehen drücken dann
hier oben auf fertig und haben das foto
jetzt unter dem namen der boss
abgespeichert dann geben wir hier oben
einfach mal der fonds ein und damals
auch schon hier habe man jetzt wieder
den bus ok nehmt das nicht zu ernst
weiter geht's mit dem nächsten
es gibt auf jeden fall auch das ein oder
andere privatsphäre update das muss man
sagen wir können zum beispiel einfach
mal hier auf instagram gehen man erteilt
instagram er das recht auf alle fotos
zuzugreifen jetzt kann man hier auf alle
fotos drücken und dann zum beispiel nur
ausgewählte fotos und kann dann halt
hier die fotos aber jetzt muss ich hier
die nacktfotos zensieren von mir und von
meinen ganzen freundinnen da kann man
halt dann auswählen auf welche fotos nur
zugegriffen werden darf
ja mir ist das an sich hatte ich habe
nichts zu verbergen glaube ich als
influenza teilt man ja eh sein ganzes
leben von daher trifft es auf mich nicht
so ein quatsch also das ist gar nicht
mal so schlecht ich finde es super gut
und ich denke das ist auch wichtig dass
das alle wissen was ich auch eben
entdeckt habe das iphone hat automatisch
meine fotos inso kategorien unterteilt
herbst reisen abendessen hochzeiten und
das sind wirklich nur fotos von
hochzeiten oder reisen oder abendessen
dann darunter sportwagen sport wo das
singen hat mein auto direkt als
sportwagen deklariert als geisteskrank
das ist wirklich heftig das gab es ja
vorher nicht oder ein handy und ich wir
verstehen uns auf jeden fall gut ein
absolutes sport auto habe ich da und was
auch noch ganz cooles wir haben hier
eine neue facetime funktion oder ich
glaube das gilt für alle anrufe wenn
jetzt gleich ein anruf reinkommt ich
hoffe jetzt kommt zufälligerweise genau
jetzt gleich ein anruf reinbekommen
jetzt einfach einen anruf rein wenn du
zum beispiel gar keinen bock auf eine
person hatte es die dich angerufen hat
dann konntest du in der zeit wo sie dich
anrufen hat nichts mit deinem handy
machen weil du das nicht wegwischen
konntest du wolltest ja auch nicht dass
die märkte okay der hat mich weggedrückt
jetzt ruft mich nämlich marie eben an
hallo ich hoffe das kommt das gleich mal
genau hier oben erscheint und dann kann
man das einfach schön hoch vision und
dann erscheint hier oben in der ecke und
du kannst alles weitermachen oder du
wirst einfach dran weil ich sehr mag
deswegen gehe ich jetzt einfach mal dran
moin moin was geht alles hier ist die
kamera einer was in die kamera sagen
bitte
man kann jetzt aber auch einfach das
gespräch hier auf den home bildschirm
ziehen und jetzt im hintergrund weiter
mit den apps interagieren absolut genial
ok marie was sagst du dass du hast du
auch schon als 14
ok dann kannst du jetzt aber das video
beenden weil das waren schon alle wenn
ihr noch mehr sehen wollt lasten super
dicken daumen nach oben da abonniert den
kanal und ja sagt matthias